- Just who,
in the hell,
do you think you are?
- Well.
- WOOOOOOOOO!
AHHHHHHHHHHHH!
- That was AWESOME!
- AHAHAHAHA!
- He's so cute!
- RAWRRRR!
- AHHHHHHHHHH!
- I am Groot.
- What's that?
- He says "Welcome to the fricking Guardians of the Galaxy".
Only he didn't use fricking.
- AHHHH
- LOOK OUT!!!
- Oh wow.
- I tried guys.
- The fate of the universe lies on your shoulders
Now whatever you do,
Don't push this button.
Cause that will set off the bomb immediately and we'll all be dead.
- Huh?
- Now repeat back what I just said.
- I am Groot!
- Noooo, no that's the button that will kill everyone!
Try again..
- I am Groot.
- Uh hmm.
- Uh huh.
- I am Groot!!
- Nooooooo!
- Shotime A-holes
- AHHHHHHHHHH!!
- Screw you, spaceships!
- Does anyone have any tape out there? I wanna put some tape over the death button.
- Nobody has any tape!
- Not a single person has tape?!
- You have an atomic bomb in your bag, if anybody's gonna have tape, it's YOU!
- I have to do EVERYTHING!
- You are wasting A LOT OF TIME!
- I...AM...GROOOOOOOOOOT!!!
- That's a really bad sign.
- If I touch someone, I can feel their feelings.
You feel...LOVE.
- Yeah, a guess-yeah. I feel uh, general, unselfish lovers but every-
- No!
Sexual LOVE.
- No, no i don't..
- For her!
- Nooo!
- AHAHAHAHA!!
- She just told everyone your deepest darkest secret!
- Dude, come on! I think you're overreacting a little bit.
- You must be so EMBARRASSED! AHAHA!
Do me! Do me! Do me!